much president Trump says he watched the
video of rashard books he called it a
terrible situation
so he's expected to sign an executive
order on police reform today Paula Reid
is at the White House with that part of
the story Paula what is this executive
order expected to say good morning Gail
senior administration officials say the
president wants to encourage a higher
standard of policing this order will
include three modest proposals that
already enjoy broad-based support the
first proposal is that they will
encourage police departments to collect
and track excessive force complaints
there will also be incentives for police
to update their training certifications
and they also encourage police to employ
mental health professionals to work
alongside police to respond to some
incidents but it's unclear how this
order will be enforced this is not
legally binding and officials say they
do not intend to link federal funding to
cooperation the national Fraternal Order
of Police say they have reviewed this
order and they are supportive of it but
this order is unlikely to satisfy
protesters because it does not directly
address racial bias in policing now the
Senate is not expected to take up a
reform bill until after its July 4th
recess senator Tim Scott who has been
leading the Republicans efforts on
reform says without a new law Congress
will have failed this moment Tony all
right Paula thank you